Dear editor, the following sequence will
only be funny if you how to basic this.
>> I'm I'm just going to apologize in
advance for this one.
[clears throat]
[music]
>> Oh,
please let me stop masturbating. Please
let me stop masturbating.
>> Don't include that.
I promised my mama that I wouldn't sell
my soul on YouTube.
It was never supposed to be like this.
To the remnant.
M
healthy.
Boys and girls, welcome back to another
thrilling episode of Atheist Church on
It. Today's a good day, but it's a
strange day. You know why?
Cuz it's a Saturday, which can only mean
that today I went and visited my friends
over at the 7th Day Adventist [music]
church. The the 7th Day Adventists at
their church. There's a lot to get into
with this whole thing. Uh, two points of
order in case you're not understanding
any of this yet. The 7th Day Adventists,
they have church on Saturday instead of
Sunday, and they are historically known
to be vegetarians. The 7th Day Adventist
Church is one that I've been wanting to
visit for a long, long time now. There's
a score of reasons for that. One of them
is they're kind of the ugly duckling,
the odd stepchild in the the theological
circles that came out of the 19th
century. It's it's certainly not fair
for me to call them that, but people
seem to know the least about them
compared to other similar groups that
sprouted in this same era. You've got
your Jehovah's Witnesses with the door
knocking and the apocalypse rocking and
uh what else do they do? Um
and the dysfellowshipping.
Then you've got your Latter-day Saints
with the golden plates and celestial
families and stuff. And then you've got
your Christian scientists who reject the
physical world and matter and everything
that you can touch, [music] feel, and
smell and stuff. And then you've got the
Seventh Day Adventists who were birthed
in the same era also by a woman like the
Christian Scientists, but they're a
curveball. And I know next to nothing
about them. In a lot of ways, they're
sort of like the final frontier for me.
There's, you know, much stranger groups
out there, but this is like one of those
groups. [music] They've just always been
on my radar. And when I think about like
the things that I know about 7th Day
Adventists,
there's not a lot there. Actually, I
wrote I wrote them down. Saturday, Ellen
White, [music]
vegetarian with a question mark next to
it, and apocalypse. How much do I know
now being on the other side of it? Um,
next to none. In case you're new to this
channel, um, here's here's what I do. I
[music] go and and and explore
denominations and churches and sex and
cults and and [music] all of that jazz.
And it usually takes a while. This video
is not any sort of information about the
7th Day Adventists. This is more so an
announcement that I will be
investigating them [music] in the
future. All of this is just my
nonsensical, ignorant ramblings. And
then maybe I'll come back to this video
in a year and be like, "Boy howdy was I
wrong about everything." So, what
happened with the Jehovah's Witnesses
videos this morning? I pulled up to the
uh 7th Day Adventist Church of Raleigh,
and I just I love this so much. I'm so
passionate, so determined that I would
forfeit my Saturday morning to go and go
to church. I had so many plans that I
had to cancel, so many people who wanted
to hang out with me. Um,
uh, Bob, uh, Bob Iger, CEO of Disney. He
wanted to hang out and I I shot him
down. [snorts]
I did.
I pulled up to this big, beautiful
church building. Um, maybe leaning a
little heavy on the 70s, you know, era
architecture, but overall, beautiful
facilities. And as per usual, I just
mosied around and and asked where to go
until somebody was like, "Go that way."
And then I went that way. I don't know
what I was expecting or what I wasn't
expecting because I have never even like
heard rumors about the 7th Day
Adventists through the grapevine. I will
be candid and say that one of the
reasons why I wanted to explore the 7th
Day Adventists is because I know that
there's a number of strange and culty
offshoots from the Seventh Day
Adventists and I knew that I needed to
explore this group before I could
explore those groups. One such group is
the branch devidians famous because of
David Caresh and Waco Texas. He was the
self-proclaimed messiah who looked like
a rock star. A messmerizing personality
and passionate Bible knowledge combined
to allow him to gain ascendancy over a
small group of followers to manipulate
them, use them for his sexual desires,
and prepare them for his own version of
Armageddon. So like that was in my gray
matter, but ultimately I I didn't know
how far of an offshoot that was from
this. Now I am not at all saying that
there's like burden of of responsibility
that the general SDA community takes for
something like an offshoot of an
offshoot with like what happened at
Waco. That's not what I'm saying. What
I'm saying is like how close, you know,
did that apple fall from the tree with
regards to like some of their
theological thinking. And I just have no
idea. And so I think if anything when I
was listening to the Sabbath school
sermon, I was just kind of struck by how
standard maybe even evangelical it
sounded. A lot of it was emphasizing,
you know, the importance of preaching
the gospel and a lot of it was
emphasizing purifying your mind and not
dwelling on crappy things. Another thing
that I'll mention is that again, this
denomination was birthed in the same era
as the Jehovah's Witnesses, Christian
Scientists, and the Latter-day Saints.
Those four were kind of the the the big
four of Christian heresy in that old
Christian classic, Kingdom of the Cults.
Uh Walter Walter
Martin. This book taught evangelicals
how to spot heresy and and and other
other eyes people. To be totally fair, I
have not read this book. However, it is
fascinating because in this book, he's
got a chapter on the Christian
scientists. He's got a chapter on
Jehovah's Witnesses, a chapter on the
Mormons, [music] and then in the
appendix, he's got the puzzle of the 7th
Day Adventists.
[music] Interesting. I've looked into
and visited all of those affformentioned
groups, and the 7th Day Adventists were
kind of the last box I needed to check
uh to to to make my way through this
strand of religious movements. And so
candidly during my visit today, I was
comparing the SDA to the Latter-day
Saints, the Christian Scientists, and
the Jehovah's Witnesses. And it was
wildly fascinating. I'm going to make a
prediction. Um, and that prediction is
that like the Latter-day Saints, the 7th
Day Adventists have done a lot of
cleanup in the past [music]
50 to 100 years. That's going to be my
guess, my sneaking suspicion. And I
think also like the Latter-day Saints,
they have probably made a very concerted
effort to squeeze back into the the the
mold of standard Protestant American
Christianity probably even no definitely
more successfully than uh the Latter-day
Saints. So general observations, the
Seventh Day Adventists like the
Jehovah's Witnesses are one of the most
racially diverse religious groups in
America. And fascinatingly,
um, they're huge. Dear editor, please,
um, uh, showcase the the numbers of how
many Latter-day Saints there are, how
many Jehovah's Witnesses there are, and
how many Christian Scientists there are
worldwide. Compare that to the number of
how many Seventh Day Adventists there
are worldwide. The Seventh Day
Adventists are substantially bigger than
the Jehovah's Witnesses or the
Latter-day Saints. And somehow I know
next to nothing about them. Like how
much media coverage has there been about
Mormonism just in the past year alone?
And then you tell people about Seventh
Day Adventism and like some of the crazy
history behind it and nobody knows it.
What is some of that crazy history?
We'll we'll we'll get there. We'll I'll
give you the the little little
sprinkling of what I discovered in, you
know, my 3 minutes of Googling. The
other thing that I'll mention with
regards to the demographics of the
attendees there is that even though the
7th day Adventist church was started by
a woman like the Christian Scientists
were here there's an equal smattering of
men and women whereas the Christian
Scientists are one of the only religious
groups that I know of that skew slightly
female. So with all that being said,
let's talk about the service. There was
a lot of very familiar churchiness that
I I didn't know that I was expecting.
There was the common thing where it's
like, "All right, turn around and greet
your neighbor." Except instead of
saying, "Peace be with you or God bless
you, brother." You would turn around and
say, "Happy Sabbath. Happy Sabbath.
Happy Sabbath." Another thing that they
did, which like I associate this with
like Methodists and Lutheran, they did
children's church up at the front of the
church. There's a a single children's
church teacher up there who's like just
teaching the group of kids at the front
of the altar and all of the adults are
just kind of, you know, sitting in the
back watching. It's kind of a weird
thing optically to just watch children
learn for 10 minutes, but it was fine.
Just imagine like a group of senior
citizens came to like a a a college
lecture and they were just watching you
being lectured. Doesn't that just seem
weird? It's fine. Like, I'm not I'm not
criticizing it. I don't know. It's just
a weird custom. And the children's
church message was really sweet, right?
It was like, "And what is this, kids?"
That's right. Shampoo. Yeah. And what is
this? It's hand soap. Yeah. Well, you
know, Jesus can clean you on the inside.
And I'm going to resist the urge to go
on a long-winded tangent about original
sin or or total depravity or anything
like that. [snorts]
The other thing was uh we were asked to
kneel for a prayer and I I I have no way
of knowing if that's like a unique thing
to this parish to this church or if
that's like a universal. However, there
were no kneelers here. You just had to
tough it out. You just had to be a a
brass knuckled military man and get your
knees on those carpeted floors. And
beyond all that, it felt like a normal
Protestant church service. Stupid
talented choir here though. Oh, there
was a lot of like full gospel vibes and
some of those soloists had like really
articulate and beautiful VBR. Well done.
Well done, y'all. And then the pastor
got up and gave his sermon. Oh, and he
was a good speaker. He was a a a
articulate, energetic shouting man FROM
THE PULPIT.
BLOOD [screaming] ALONE MOVES THE WHEELS
OF HISTORY.
>> And most of the points from his sermon
were solid. I'm an atheist, so like
there there's things that I disagree
with, but I'm I'm specifically looking
for things that are like major red flags
that distinguish this group from other
Christian denominations or sex. And I
didn't see any on first glance. If I
squinted, I could maybe, you know, see
like little little sprinkles of things
that like are worth looking into more.
But overall, it just sounded like a
Biblebased
sermon. Speaking of Bible, there was a
lot of Bible. The one thing that stood
out in my mind from the sermon is, you
know, he talked about the uncertainty in
the world. You know, I was talking to
this friend and he said, "There's just
so many scandals on the news nowadays,
and there's fake news and and this story
and that story, and I can't make sense
of what's what anymore. I can't tell
what's true anymore." And then the
pastor holds up his Bible over his head
and says, "Church, this is true." And,
you know, got some applause. And it was
it was, you know, it was what it was. So
just at first glance, I would say that
like it seems like the 7th Day Adventist
emphasis on the Bible is getting close
to approximating the the passion for the
Bible that the Jehovah's Witnesses have.
But now the one thing that I was
listening for that I didn't hear
anywhere throughout the service um was a
mention of their founding prophetus,
Ellen G. White. Now, maybe it's not that
interesting to Adventists. Maybe it's
not that interesting to all all of
y'all, but for me as a person trying to
like figure out where these people sit
on the theological map, it's
interesting. I don't know. I'm sure that
sometimes you can go into a Mormon ward
and not hear the name Joseph Smith, but
I'm sure that that's more rare. I I
mean, he's pretty heavily emphasized in
their normal talks. On the other hand,
you cannot walk into a Christian Science
church and not hear the name Mary Baker
Eddie. literally cannot sit through a
service without hearing a reading from
science and health with key to their
scriptures which is like their central
text that they read alongside the Bible.
It's literally like on the the walls of
their building. You'll have the Bible on
one hand and science and health with key
to the scriptures by Mary Baker Eddie on
the other. On the other hand, the
Jehovah's Witnesses, most of them don't
know anything about Charles Tae Russell,
the guy who started that thing. And so I
was listening to to hear like how
heavily emphasized she was in the
service and she wasn't. Ellen G. White
was not mentioned unless I unless I
missed something. I did flip through
their little quarterly Bible study thing
and and found some quotes from her. It
it was just a quote. Somebody gave me
this and I was I was very curious about
it. So this is a daily devotional and
immediately when I saw it, my heart sank
a little bit and I was like, "Oh no,
it's like the watchtower." Because the
Jehovah's Witnesses also have like a
thing that they go through weekly, but
the amount of emphasis that they place
on it. I mean, it's like the Watchtower
is it's not the Bible because it's
referencing the Bible, but I mean, it's
so highly regarded there. And they're
they're very rigid about how you ought
to study the Watchtower and and how you
need to come prepared with the answers
and how you need to be able to come and
give a two sentence summary of what you
read that week. And so, this is a
literal daily devotional that everyone
in the church is going through. And I'm
sure that I could quote mine some some
less than savory parts of it, but I
don't know that there's the same sort of
heavy-handed doineering and expectation
that everyone has to go through this in
the same way the Jehovah's Witnesses do.
Case in point, the guy who gave it to me
was like, "Ah, yeah, I meant to get to
it this week, but you know, it's just
been a crazy week." I don't think that
would fly too well if you said that to
an elder at a Jehovah's Witness Kingdom
Hall. Again, literally spent 2 hours at
this place. I don't know a whole lot. I
reserve the right to rescend all of
these statements and wse at this video
in the future. So, yeah, that was
today's service. I I shook some hands.
Um had a had a really delightful time.
As I got up to leave, I bumped shoulders
with the guy who was teaching the
Sabbath school class and I thanked him
and I'm an idiot and I said, "Thanks so
much for teaching Sunday school." Oh, I
I mean um um um um and he was like, "No,
no, no. It's okay. I used to go to a
Sunday attendance church as well." And
listen, those people are my brothers.
And I've done this rodeo enough to know
it can be a little bit more complicated,
you know, like sometimes the way that
members will talk to visitors, they'll
sometimes water down the less savory
aspects of their doctrine. So glad to
hear that this guy, you know, considers
the larger Christian community his
brothers and sisters. In what capacity
he sees that connection and that
relationship is yet to be seen? I I
don't know. I I I hope it's good because
we don't we don't like when groups are
just kind of off in the in the weeds
doing their own thing because I think it
leads to bad outcomes. So that's where
the church is at now. That's where I
think the church is at now. But let's
talk about where the church came from.
So we need to rewind the clock all the
way back to 1844.
Back in yonder years, there was an old
Baptist preacher named William Miller.
and he predicted that Jesus would
[music] return somewhere around 1843
1844 when Jesus did no come back in in
1844. That event was called the great
[music] disappointment. And it's
difficult to overestimate how huge of an
effect that had on the American
religious [music] landscape. However, in
the midst of trying to figure out WTF
happened with Jesus not coming back in
1844, there were some people who tried
to reinterpret the event and say that
no, the date was correct, but the event
was not what we understood. Instead,
Jesus wasn't coming back to earth. He
was entering the most holy place [music]
in heaven. And there was a lot of
different groups with a lot of, you
know, evolving thoughts and ideas. But
one group kind of materialized that
[music] also began to say that the
Sabbath should be celebrated on Saturday
instead of Sunday. They were devoting
themselves to holistic living. Then LG
White comes along, a young woman who was
massively, massively pivotal in the 7th
Day Adventist movement, and she is still
pivotal to this day. She had visions
throughout her life, hundreds of visions
and [music] wrote extensively. She was
very very prolific. She wrote thousands,
[music]
thousands and thousands and thousands of
pages. Um, all of which are still
considered sacred and inspired by 7th
Day Adventists, though not on par with
scripture. And then the most important
contribution that Ellen G. White made
was that the apocalypse was very, very
eminent. So Jesus is like, you know,
he's he's doing his final check, making
sure he crossed his tees and dotted his
eyes with the book of [music] life
before coming and finally bringing in
the new heavens and the new earth. The
the apocalypse is imminent. And from
what I can gather, it looks like Ellen
G. White and and later Adventists would
point to Sunday worship as a signifier
of the mark of the beast. like maybe
it's not the mark of the beast itself,
but it is like a symbol of the the evils
of the the the church. And so it it
sounds like there was paranoia that like
the US government was going to
mandatorily enforce Sunday worship and
like Sabbathkeeping laws, but but Sunday
Sabbath rather than Saturday Sabbath.
>> I don't agree with you one bit. I'm
still a little hazy on it, but but from
what I gather, because early Adventists
were concerned with the government
imposing bad religious rules on them,
they were big and and very passionate
about the separation of church and
state. So, they were anti-Christian
nationalists, counterintuitively, right?
As an aside, I think that that's one of
the interesting things about studying
some of these groups. Like sometimes you
assume that people who are in high
control groups or sects or like fringe
religious movements would be like some
of the most politically problematic
people, but sometimes they become like
unlikely bedfellows with progressive
politicians.
>> It's an honor to address the members of
the 7th Day Adventist Church.
>> That's probably an overstatement, but
like Jehovah's Witnesses have zero
patience for Christian nationalism
because they're not allowed to be in
politics. There's not a slew of
Jehovah's Witnesses who are voting for
Donald Trump or rooting for JD Vance.
That that's not a thing. That's not to
say they're not conservative, but but it
is to say that like you you have to have
a holistic understanding of their
worldview or else you'll make the
mistake of lumping them in with other
people that they're not like. What up?
Filming a podcast. Let's go. Let's
[__]
Let's [__] show those [__] woke
idiot dumb [__] Let's [__] go.
Let's [__] go. [laughter] But then
maybe one of the long-standing oddities
of the Seventh Day Adventists is their
emphasis on health and wellness and
vegetarianism. And I have talked to two
Adventists up to this point for all of
two minutes. I don't know the extent of
their dietary restrictions these days. I
don't know how strictly these things are
enforced, whether they're encouraged,
whether they're belittled or or or
pressured into, you know, some of these
things. But at bare minimum, it seems
that vegetarianism is esteemed as being
spiritually superior to carnivorism or
or what's what's the other one?
Omnivorism.
omni vor vorism. But I think the reason
behind the vegetarianism is something
that is wildly wildly funny. So all of
this comes from an era where people were
just just really going haywire with
medical theories and ideas and and a
little bit of woowoo if I can if I can
be so insulting. Sorry to my SDA
friends. But you also see this with the
Latter-day Saints and with the Christian
Scientists. There was kind of a
prevailing theory that anything that
tasted good
was bad. There's a really good video on
this by knowing better. Um, it looks
like this. I'm going to I'm going to
link down to that video down below. It's
it's really good. I don't think I
finished it. He goes into some of the
insane oddities of that era. Um, and
it's it's wacky. But part of the gist of
it was that they thought that like foods
that taste good um weaken your spirit
and ruin your body. And the other thing
that ruins your body is masturbation.
And as a guy who was a nofapper for
seven years,
I dispute that claim. Sometimes I'll see
these people like pop up who talk about
like nofap like it's the greatest thing
that God ever created. And if you can
just abstain from masturbating, you're
just your muscles will get bigger, your
face will get prettier, your locks will
grow more lusciously. And man, if the
any of that were true, I would look like
Hulk Hogan married Timothy Shalamé
married
I don't know, uh,
Pikachu. But no, unfortunately, I just
look like this. So masturbation was a
big no no. Tasty foods were a big no no.
And Kellogg was a major player in the
7th Day Adventist movement there at the
beginning. Dr. John Harvey Kellogg of
serial fame invented the cornflakes as
an anti-masturbatory tool. He wanted you
to eat boring food because that would
make you less lustful and less likely to
commit adultery or masturbate or think
naughty thoughts. And also he was really
into enemas like like bowel cleaning
like just
[__] His health facility that that he
made um gave enemas to William Taft and
Henry Ford
and somehow that was like co-signed by
by the Seventh Day Adventists. I am so
confused. So with all of this, I don't
know if this is like a really
underwhelming video. I don't know if all
of this is just a big nothing burger,
but the 7th Day Adventists,
they seem really pleasant now. It seemed
just pretty generally Christian. I I
don't know. I I don't I don't know. It
It may very well be the case that the
Seventh Day Adventists had a a doozy of
a start, a wild wild time. But my hope
is that they've reinterpreted their
history, which I think that groups are
allowed to do. I think that religious
movements are often really embarrassed
by some of the things that they've done
in the past and my mo tends to be to,
you know, not rub dirt on their faces
for it cuz I think that makes reforming
harder. I don't really care where they
came from. I care where they're going. I
do care where they came from and and you
can't make sense of where you are now
without knowing where you came from. But
I know the difficulty and you know the
the pain of having to make sense of your
philosophical history or your
theological history or your cultural
history. And I'm not out to make that
journey more difficult or more painful
than it needs to be for people who are
trying to grapple with stuff like that.
My ultimate hope for these churches is
that they're well and that they're
treating people well today. And even if
there's a little bit of moral wrestling
and cognitive dissonance that goes into
that equation, I'm not going to lose
sleep over it. So, all in all, I have a
lot more reading to do. Again, this is a
god, I'm going to come back to this
video in like two months and be like,
"Wow, Jared, you're an idiot." But I
think that it's important for people to
kind of see my initial reactions and see
how they change over time because uh
that's what learning looks like. And I
hope that we can all learn a little bit.
Aw. A.
So, I already clapped. My name is Jared.
I'm an atheist. Go to church. And scene.
And scene.
Cut it. Cut it hard. CUT IT RIGHT THERE.
CUT IT HARD.
[music]
I'm now going to show you my belly
button.
>> Every day we stray further from God.